all right
we are live tamuwa we are live my friend
oh my gosh
uh so here we go
hot breath the verse welcome back to hot
breath the show where you learn comedy
from the pros
i am your host comedian joel byers and
my heart is smiling today because
i've interviewed over 400 comedians and
i get contacted daily
from comedians
like either
just saying how much they love the show
or asking for advice
this comic today
i i went back and checked the dms he can
he connected with me in february of 2020
when he was working on a podcast
since then
he has now gone viral he just sold out
the blaisdale center in hawaii 2100
people
capacity
that's over 6 000 people that this cat
only five years into the comedy game has
sold out and he's just getting started
so please welcome to the stage
tamuwa
hold on hold on i wrote hold on i wrote
this down
i didn't want to be the colonizer who
missed you now yeah i just changed they
just say my first name so you don't have
to say the last two
a couple of the uh interviews i
researched you on they mispronounced it
i'll say
probably yeah i don't know but yeah they
just
two more just my one one name person but
thank you thank you for having me joel
i'm sorry man like the one thing i want
to do is get your name right and then
now i look oh you got it right now just
towards the best that's
people mispronounced that too but you
got it right okay okay okay all right
well welcome to the hot breath verse my
friend it's so great to uh
meet you virtually i know we've been in
contact we even talked about it one time
i think this was pre pandemic about like
me making a trip out to hawaii and doing
some [__] yeah which we're still we have
a lot of a lot of venues i mean the blue
note is a perfect
club you know a lot of mainland comics
come here and perform there and just let
me know i mean we can put something
together
i feel like that may have been
because you know i've been i've been
keeping up with you like since you dm'd
me and i was like oh this cat's on to
something i think you sold out the blue
note
and uh and then it's just grown from
there but i have seen your progression
from like doing local shows doing social
media to now selling out 2100 people
dude five years into comedy
the power of social media this is the
few like you're you're a prime example
of
like i hate to say it for the purest out
there and i'll say i've been a comedian
12 years
so even when i started
social media wasn't around this new wave
of how to pursue comedy and i've
interviewed all the top like managers
and agents and bookers and they're all
saying the game is now social media yeah
you've you've tapped into it man so so
congratulations to you and um thank you
please give give a little context here
as uh we're welcoming people in we
already have some people asking
questions
but please do just give a little context
for
kind of your your journey to how you got
to be on the hot breath podcast
yeah i'm honored to be here i mean i
told you before i'm a fan of the the
podcast and and i would actually listen
to to a lot of your um episodes and your
guest comics and and take the the very
helpful tips that i still use today and
to joke writing and and being consistent
i'm still learning every day to be
better but pretty much yeah i started
doing stand-up first before i did the
videos um because um i took a stand-up
comedy class at university of hawaii in
college they had a class and i just took
it just just to get an easy a and then
for our final presentation
um
of the semester we had to perform 10
live minutes in front of an actual
audience in this bar
and um when i did it the whole the whole
football team showed up i was on the
football team too so the whole football
team showed up and um i i crushed it i
killed it for 10 minutes and then a
comedy promoter saw me there and then he
kept inviting me um
to come back again and again and i
started opening for like
comedians i would come down to hawaii
and um doing small spots here and there
i only this is like my first year in i
only had maybe 10 15 20 minutes of
material and i'm just
constantly doing that and then um when i
and i built an hour um i did my first
headlining show
at this venue called hawaiian brian's
and that was like my
the same month that i graduated college
so at this time i was doing stand-up and
football division one football and just
um balancing the two things you know the
two sports i call them boat sports
because i sweat on stage a lot
and then from there like i had this
monthly spot i would do
um on the east side of the island um
every second friday of the month i would
headline and they would have some local
people coming here and there and i kept
doing this until um until 2020 until the
pandemic and then when march 2020 the
pandemic hit real hard in hawaii um
everything shut down you know so i had
that monthly spot
that closed that restaurant in that golf
course is that a golf course it shut
down and all these other small shows you
would have like weekly comedy shows in
hawaii that shut down too
and i was just at home thinking like
what am i gonna do now i mean this is
what i always wanted to do did i just
not do anything or do i
try to figure out something so i put out
this um this viral video of this toilet
paper dealer like a drug drug dealer
toilet paper is a hot topic at the time
and i put that video out and that day i
put it out it made it on the local news
on tv and um
and actually like it actually made it to
like the new zealand news too like this
viral hog or this company like bought
the video from me because they were so
invested in it and i just sold it to
them just because i didn't i was like
i'm not making money anyhow so i just
sold it just for like 300 bucks or
whatever what
yeah they they paid for that that first
video i put up but i never sold any
other videos i it's better to just keep
them keep them now and and get paid with
the views now that i'm like monetized on
youtube and stuff
but um yeah from there i'll say okay
this is what this is what the people of
hawaii want they want these these skits
you know so i started putting out more
and more skits and and
kind of geared more towards the local
audience um and it just kept going viral
in the islands you know and my followers
kept growing and growing and growing and
then when we finally got the green light
to do live shows again in hawaii um i
just put up two shows at the blue note
this was like october of 2020 and as
soon as i put it on sale it sold out
within like 15 minutes and this is the
capacity it was like 200 people per show
so the two shows sold out in 10 minutes
and then so we added another two and
another two and another two and i ended
up doing um 18 shows in a row at blue
note
both yeah so
and then so that's when me and my
manager were like oh you can actually
like do do the blaze though now because
like all these people were just just
coming out for that and
yeah after i did the blue note i mean
then we we put on the
we put on the blaze though for sale and
um the first show
is 2100 people at the blaisdell the
blazo theater and um yeah that sold out
in an hour
and um so we added a second show the
week after that
and um that one sold out in hour two and
then we added a third show and then that
one didn't sell out the day of but um it
eventually sold out as the weeks came
closer to the show so so we did three
shows friday saturday sunday um
in december
2021 and um yeah it was just happening
so quick and and like big time comedians
were noticing that i mean joke i talked
to joe coy and he's he gave me a shout
out on social media bert kreischer um
ronnie chang to all these guys i mean
they're it's crazy that they're like my
idols that i looked up to you know and
now just
performing at some of the venues that
they performed at and it's all happening
so quick and it's all thanks to to
social media like you said it's the new
that's the new marketing these days you
know and we didn't do it any any
promoter no no big promotion company
just just me and my manager just put it
up on social media and and it sold so
and i'm still growing you know with
comedy and learning you know different
strategies and
how to
you know maintain an audience for a full
hour and all that so
my plans coming up is i'm going to do
some comedy in the mainland so where
where are you at right now where are you
located i'm in atlanta
atlanta okay yeah i'm just doing mostly
uh west coast so
ah
right now so i mean getting all like the
the strong
was that i said i mean who knows though
you know maybe yeah who knows yeah yeah
well right now i'm just hitting all the
the strong hawaiian population so vegas
is huge um there's a lot of hawaii
people there vegas um utah
you know seattle portland you know some
spots in in california and irvine this
year in san jose
this year yeah so starting in april or
the ending of march but we got some
places booked already but
once i have it all booked i'm gonna
gonna announce some some dates so
oh yeah yeah let's keep in touch on that
because i've um
i've been looking to make a trip out to
vegas because um
i've been contact do you know laugh
after dark have you heard of that
show they do in vegas
it's called laugh after dark
no no uh well they they're now like
producing like comedy specials and stuff
but i've been in contact with them about
doing an interview so um maybe there's a
way to parlay a double uh a double dip
in there yeah yeah yeah yeah so we'll
see what's goody there um it's it the
hardest it's like all these other spots
are easy to find like venues but vegas
is tough because there's so many so many
spots so many clubs and you don't know
which which one to pick and it's kind of
expensive there too but that's
definitely you know the one of the main
spots i want to hit just because of the
the hawaii population there and that's
probably the most request requested spot
i've gotten so far is to come to vegas
and perform so i'm excited for that and
excited to get my feet wet in in the
mainland we call it the mainland us
local people here so
yeah that's crazy to think five years
and you're doing an hour's show and i i
saw in like your promo
for the blaisdell like showing like that
sellout and everything that it looked
like you had a t-shirt cannon did you
maybe have a friend like did your
openers come back on stage with you did
you guys do something together like
yeah so um i'm just saying five years in
dude to do an hour like yeah so i had a
long time for people that don't
understand comedy yeah like that's no
joke i started doing an hour like my
first time in an hour was it was a year
in
but i would say it wasn't as strong as
how it is now you know like just making
it more tight and and just yeah so yeah
that was a t-shirt cannon so i was
shooting out my merch at the end some
t-shirts just to make them excited yeah
and then um
i think he saw uh my friend josh tatoffi
so he's actually a
musician here in hawaii and he's um
really popular so he was i had him
backstage and then he just sang one song
at the end just as a surprise
for the for the audience but um yeah you
should check him out too he has a couple
grammy nominations and he's pretty
pretty popular oh wow
but yeah so that's why you probably saw
that in the video but yeah
five years and i mean just like i said
this is
people don't really know that that's
actually really young in the common
years you know and people are still
and i'm still learning as myself i'm
getting more comfortable with um with
crowd work i try to do that a lot too
just
seeing um andrew schultz and and all
these guys russell peters and how they
do that
but um but yeah still learning
everything and taking it all in like a
like a sponge
so for social media for the social media
grind here um what and for people
watching live do comment with your
questions and i'm happy to get to your
questions as well
but like
how
when you
social media is so much about
consistency and i remember in your early
grind like every time i opened social
media it felt like i was seeing you
doing another skit so it's how as me
being a comedian
sometimes i'll go on a run for like a
week or two and i was like
this is the time i do social media and
then like two weeks later i'm like oh i
miss post here i miss a post there
like how how are you able to keep up
consistency even if maybe it's like not
like quote working
i i would like try to give myself a like
a timeline so
back in my when i first started pumping
out lots of videos i would try to post a
video like every
four or five days i would have something
and these videos would be
not just
short 30 second videos it would actually
be like
you know two to three minute videos and
um
[Music]
the hardest part is just editing you
know so i mean like like charlie burns
you said you know um like i give him
props because every time i open up my
feed too he has a video every day a new
video you know so it's tough i mean the
editing process is hard because
you sit there for hours just trying to
get the perfect cut in and even if you
put the subtitles up that that that's a
headache too but it's all worth it you
know and i really enjoyed you know
editing and
and the tech side of
of making videos and all that so
i guess
i had a timeline so every four or five
days i'll put up a video and that would
kind of you know force me to
to do that now i probably do it maybe
like
every once a week maybe you know
i try to do once a week i gotta post one
soon but but it's tough but i like
there's two sides of my comedy like my
my skits and my my stand up like my
skits i i really don't write anything
down for that i just have the idea in my
head or the premise or the character i
want to portray and then um i just get
my friend or whoever i'm doing the video
with and just
have the camera rolling and and just
improv right there and i just cut and
take the the best parts and just chop it
up into like a two minute video and post
that you know so you do it all yourself
but you do the editing and all yeah
everything you know everything myself
wow even all my comedy flyers i edit
them all and do all that all the press
release all through me
yeah comedians nowadays i mean you're
like your own media company like we do
we not only have to learn marketing
stand up yeah but market ourselves
create our own content editing it like
all that plays into being i think
giannis papas said that on this podcast
was like it's no longer enough just to
be a stand-up he's like you have to be
everything now
yeah i do everything and then my my
manager he's a great help too and he
just helps me book the venues and
and negotiate deals and does all the the
business side but but yeah all the
editing and the editing videos is is
where you put in the most time i i
believe
how do you come up with ideas for your
videos do you like have like a
brainstorming session where you think
about a bunch of videos and then you
record them all at once are you more
kind of shooting from the hip based on
what you think of
yeah just whatever comes into my head
first i mean
before i would do like
like like you said couple videos in one
one session and then slowly
you know post it that's probably the
best way to do it and it shows that
you're you're pumping out videos weekly
but but now it's just like whenever i
have an idea i try to find the location
that i can film it at um and then
bring my friends or whoever that i
haven't to want to be in the video and
and just do it right there um
it's tough like some like i did a video
in costco like how um
how it is like shopping in costco and
and down we just we just rushed it and
just did it
in the store without asking for
permission but um like
like people recognized me in hawaii a
lot and so they were all okay with it
the workers were fine with it and
they're even
asking to be in the video too so i mean
that's that's because people ask like
how do you get access to all these
places and i just i honestly just just
do it you know sometimes you might they
might might get in trouble but i can't
mention that right now but um you got in
trouble have you gotten in trouble a few
times yeah but nothing nothing major
just like oh you can't you can't film in
here yeah yeah but
um but yeah hawaii is very supportive
it's a it's a great community um i mean
we live on an island so it's just us
here but whenever they see like a local
boy you know succeeding and and doing
well they always want to support and
that's why what i love about this place
you know
yeah i think that's a good
thing for like comics to find wherever
they're from or like finding out it's
like you mentioned charlie barons
earlier who yeah i had on here and he's
vi he goes viral all the time being a
midwest comics so he like he found like
a a specific audience to cater to and
that seems to be
the internet's infinite social media is
infinite so you've instead of trying to
entertain everyone you've really got to
figure out like who is your audience and
just yeah just cater to that and it'll
grow from there
that's what i was talking to my friend
um
sean felipe do you know who that is
he's a filipino comedian but he's from
hawaii but he's in he's in san francisco
right now just doing comedy he does
cruise ships for a living so he does
comedy on there so yeah um the
underground comedians but he's real
funny but he he's been doing it for a
while too and he told me he realized um
that like netflix or all the big time
bookers and companies they don't want to
see the typical
white or black comedian you know they
want to see the unique they want to see
the unique comedian
straight white guys are over man
but it makes sense it makes sense what
you said about about charlie and like
because i tell people that like like how
i don't know how i'm gonna do it like in
in the mainland or the west coast but he
told me like don't change a thing just
still do your your hawaii style comedy
your fans you have a fan base they're
gonna come to you no matter what and
it's gonna it's gonna grow in and i
believe that's what what joe coy did
with his filipino community you know and
it he grew and he's one of the top
comedians right now and he has i think
he made like
i forget they had that ranking for like
the top tours
um of 2021 and he was he was like number
five or something like including with
all musicians and everything so oh
yeah
he's up there you know so
i'm just gonna stay true to my my hawaii
people and and branch out from there but
what what would you recommend for a
comic wanting to like
start
it's like
for like a comic like me who's like okay
now's the time
i'm hearing this interview i'm inspired
i'm gonna now take social media by storm
like how would you just like on stage as
a comedian you have to find your voice i
think there's a voice on social media
like what kind of tips do you have for
finding your voice on social media
i guess just finding your niche you know
like what what works um
i think in the beginning like tik tok
was uh was big in 2020 when the pandemic
first hit so i i was on tick tock too
and i was doing what everybody tries to
do just those cringy trends and all that
and it didn't do well you know it didn't
do whatever either yeah
and then i was like oh it's not working
i kind of like put that to the side and
and then when i did um you know more
like local hawaii things that you know
only hawaii people would understand then
they got a little spark and i was like
oh okay and then so i kind of just
geared it towards that that character
kind of like charlie like he has that
midwest character and i just have that
you know hawaii local boy character you
know he's kind of kind of stupid just
you know not afraid to do do anything
but it's all similar like like
desi banks does like the hood guys or
for the black community and and even
like like for white people like rednecks
they're all it's all similar you know
it's it's all
it's it's very very similar and you just
gotta find what what works with you you
know so um like i was there too i was
trying i was throwing up whatever you
know
hits the fan or whatever and and i
landed a spot with with my local niche
and hawaii people was pretty much my fan
base so
i say just keep trying whatever whatever
works it hurts though in those early
stages like you said you're throwing
stuff up it's like
you're just like oh what do you mean my
first video didn't go viral it's like do
that process of throwing stuff up like
was there was there something that kept
you motivated or you just were just like
i mean i'm doing this because i have no
choice like this is what i'm gonna do
probably um like stand up because i feel
like the
the difference with like us like people
who actually do stand up and like social
media because i know a lot of guys um
who just do social media videos and or
they're trying to do that and they don't
they don't do stand up so i mean my main
goal was like i'm sure that's your goal
too is just to make it as a stand-up
comedian so i was just doing these
videos to help push my stand-up career
and like i would i would have you know
a small fan base before i went viral
with social media like i had about maybe
like four or five thousand followers on
instagram um so like and i had that
monthly show i had that i mentioned but
nothing as compared to now and that's
all from with social media so stand up
was my motivation and it just kept me
you know to keep pursuing and keep
trying and i was just thinking okay if
this these videos don't work then i'm
just gonna just go harder and stand up
you know but yeah so it's like
remembering yeah what you're doing it
for it's like what you're doing it for
yeah not doing it for like a quick hit
but i'm really doing it to pursue my
dream comedian and this is part of it
yeah because some people are doing it to
get so they'll get popular and famous on
social media but i was doing it to get
more people at my shows you know
so
yeah just know your reason why you're
doing it i guess it would help with your
motivation
yeah and i mean a lot like you and i
don't think a lot of people that want to
pursue comedy i'm actually uh
david asked a good question here
but like this is leading to that but it
is like the grind of being a comedian
you know for me it was
you know working a day job and then
being out until 1am doing shows and then
being back at that day job the next day
for you
you were doing football
then school
and then doing comedy at night and just
rinse and repeat that cycle you know so
that that's that's the grind of comment
i don't think people really understand
that it requires you don't just wake up
on netflix like there's a lot of
sacrifice involved
yeah
it is and it's funny because i just
watched your uh your video you posted on
on youtube about you're saying that you
had a you had a show coming up in two
days and
and it was it was
did
did that show happen
it did happen my wife got sick that day
so i had to find a guest host real quick
but we ended up it's a show at a brewery
so we ended up getting about 45 people
in there and the capacity is like 60 in
there so that's great that's so great
yeah yeah nine tickets is considered
sold out too with kova restrictions so
so you're good yeah yeah i was super
happy with it but yeah someone else
asked me they're like did you have any
footage of the show and literally my
wife got sick that day and i i had to
stay home you know for the for the fam
you know that's part of
part of my parameters i set as a
comedian and like pursuing this
as a career is like
for me family is still a very important
factor of this journey and i'm not oh
yeah for sure not someone yeah i
every every decision i make is also with
my family and mind in terms of like okay
how will this affect
how long i'm away from my family that's
gonna affect the pay you know like if
someone asked me for a gig on the road
i'm like okay i'll be traveling this
much i'm gonna be missing x y and z with
my family so it's gonna be this price
and i always bake that into any of my
decisions now is like oh yeah my family
that's what i'm part of starting to
realize too like the more business side
of of gigs like as you do bigger shows
and it's a whole nother whole other
level like putting on those blaisdell
shows and it's such a headache because
it's
because we didn't do it with a promoter
so we we paid for the expenses ourself
and it's just like you got to pay for
the union dues like um the lighting guy
you know the audio guy security ushers
police there's so much that goes on into
one big production you know so but it
was all fun and it was a a great process
to see the behind the scenes of the
business work and
and like he said social media is
everything like bookers they don't like
i feel like today they don't really care
if you're funny or not they just want to
see like how much followers you have if
you can put people in the seats and then
they'll they'll book you you know but if
you if you do bad then they probably
won't book you again but but everything
is is social media these days
so did you have to with that blaisdell
show did you have to
rent it and then start selling tickets
or did you yeah so we
we rented it yeah rented it so you had
to put all that up front and then be
like oh i hope i sell these
yeah well the yeah the yeah pretty much
yeah some some of it was up front yeah
but they usually take a cut from it at
the at the end
oh okay i guess there's different deals
for different whatever yeah yeah yeah
but you got to get you got to get
approved like you can't just have anyone
go up and rent it but like you got they
got a like you gotta have some
credibility you know so when they seen
like the 18 sold out shows that at blue
note you know and that added up to more
than 2 100 people so it made sense to
put on a put on a show but were they
weren't open like blaisdell wasn't open
because of the pandemic and they weren't
doing that big of a show
with that much people
um until
like um
like right around like the month before
my show they they gave the green light
so the tickets was on sale while it was
still closed so like 100 capacity it was
like i put it on sale while it was
closed so it was almost like a gamble
yeah like is it are they even gonna be
allowed to have this much people in
december you know like even um gabriel
iglesias he was supposed to perform last
week here in hawaii but they made that
new rule where they can't go anything
more than a thousand people so he had to
postpone his show and i think he's
coming back in september wow
yeah yeah dude it's crazy covert is nuts
like oh yeah oh yeah i mean ruining us
big time
my my january was all canceled like i
like i have a fundraiser show at the end
of this month but like yeah it was i was
like all right 2022 here we go baby yeah
just like 2020 i was going to be a
touring headliner and then that went
away overnight and then now 2020 i was
like we're coming back and then it was
like oh no yeah
yeah i'm doing maui next month at the
castle theater um
which is a different island than oahu
but
uh yeah that one's that one's like sold
out already too there's only single
seats left but they might postpone it if
they don't allow you know
that much people but hopefully it's it's
it still goes you know what what's kind
of quite some time tell me the feeling
uh like i want to live vicariously
through you because i've killed in front
of
1500 people and that was for like 15
minutes like
for you to
like 2100 people that came to see you
like just that i can't i'm sure you're
still buzzing from it but like what was
that experience like being five years in
you made this happen you know like this
is your show 2100 people like what was
that feeling
it was a crazy feeling i mean um
when i first put the show on sale and
seen seen the tickets disappear in front
of my eyes on ticketmaster you can see
the dots disappear you know when you
click the whenever you buy a show and
and like that that was surreal at that
moment you know and my parents and my
family was was all tripping out on it
and the first night i remember friday
night december 10th and
walking out on that stage and hearing
the 2100 people that all came for me it
was such a crazy experience and i was
just so thankful and blessed and
i was telling my manager after the show
like it honestly felt like
any other show that i've done for some
reason it didn't feel like
because it was it's just so dark out
there too like if you look in the
theater i mean i've done theater shows
before but same like you just opening
but
just to have
your own fans come to your show and
purely just off of social media is a
crazy experience but then again it's
just it's just comedy and it's just
another another show you know
but it is on a bigger level and i mean i
got some tips from other comedians of
telling me how to pace myself more
because it's a bigger venue and you know
your sound travels slower so you know
you can't talk too fast and you gotta
let the laughs ride
and look up a lot too because there's
people in the balcony and
it's just different yeah and then kind
of pace yourself across the whole stage
i mean there's little tips here and
there that would make make it more
better and more crisp but yeah such a
crazy experience and i'll never forget
it and i'm just thankful
for having it and thankful for the
people of hawaii for supporting me
were you like
feel like you were like electrified like
that high after a show like we're all we
all chase it for like that's we love
comedy because you get high from it but
i can't imagine you must have that was
like
that was really yeah i was really
nervous before but then after you know
that first
few laughs i got in the beginning it
went away and i just started to enjoy it
and then and then after that first show
i was like okay i want to do this again
i can't wait for tomorrow for the second
show and then yeah the third show you
know yeah probably floating you probably
you can't tell me nothing
do you know who i am
yeah it's so dope it was fun it was it
was great you know and we're planning to
do the the arena this year at the end of
the year so
but that also means i got to flip a
whole new hour of material
stupidity i don't know i don't know how
those like like jo koy them or the the
big time comics they produce new hours
of material like every year or two years
because
we know it takes multiple years to get a
polished hour act you know
and a lot of stage time
a lot of stage time yeah but yeah you
got to think these guys are
headlining like you know six shows a
week so they're probably writing new
material on stage as they do it too so
yeah and you can weave it in you know if
you're like going on tour you know you
can always couch some newer stuff in or
you know not necessarily do all new but
find moments to try something new and
then if it doesn't work you go back to
what works you know you can always kind
of
weave in newer material to test it out
without really the show suffering for it
you know that's what that's what i did
like at that blue note or like when i
had that monthly spot i would i would um
yeah kind of weave in the new material
and just test it out right there because
then again it's it's your but yeah it's
your fans too so they might laugh at no
matter what you say
but um but you are performing for your
audience but
but yeah it's good to just try out new
material on stage yeah that is a good
point yeah they're there to see you so
you you do get some leeway there as well
yeah they're just like oh my gosh it's
him from the screen
but you still got to be funny though yes
oh yeah yeah yeah no it's not easy yeah
i was not implying that like oh you got
it easy now man no definitely definitely
not
um let's see
uh david iraqi
sounds like he's in hawaii
um i don't know if you've heard
of him um but he asks
what was your journey in comedy like
starting in hawaii do you have any tips
for people starting out in hawaii
oh um
i took the comedy class at at um
my college university of hawaii um i
think that's like they don't have it
anymore i don't think they have any
classes in hawaii but
that that really helped me a lot and
i wasn't expecting
to actually perform in the class i
thought it was just like learning about
stand-up comedy and the history about it
they actually made you go to open mics
throughout the semester and like have
the the owner of the mic or the
restaurant or whatever to sign off um a
slip that you perform so that was a
requirement of the class or else you
would you would fail the class so i
would say just get out and and find open
mics you know
the hardest part is starting i know joel
probably agrees with that too but
i get so much people come up to me and
say oh i wanna do stand up i wanna i
wanna what do you want me to do and i
said just go to an open mic and the
first thing they say is oh i i don't
know if i'm ready i'm scared or i only
have
two minutes or
the main thing just get up there even if
you don't have anything to say i feel
like the first time just riff or just
say something for two or three minutes
and just get that get used to being on
stage you know that's the how to start
it off
yeah start yeah starting is the hardest
part yeah i say that all the time and i
guess for if david's looking for stage
time in hawaii like is there like a
facebook group or like a calendar
somewhere of the shows or
yeah there's a facebook um hawaii
comedians or
they have a bunch of hawaii comedians
are um
i think it's i think it's just hawaii
comedians on facebook um
they have a bunch of of weekly shows or
you can um hit up one of the comedy
promoters on there and um
there's actually yeah there's a show um
if you're ever in hawaii david but um i
think every wednesdays
there's open mic so tonight there's an
open mic after their feature show
at um anna o'brien's
which is in in town this irish pub bar
oh i love it if you're in hawaii david
so yeah you can even come out tonight
check it out three minutes
tonight tonight
how do you start in comedy when you get
on stage what did it mean you know
comedy yeah yeah
hypothetical right now i'll sign you up
yeah you told me there's a few hawaiian
comics to like this show so
you know you never know who's listening
right now
and this show's a great resource too if
you're like wanting to start out in
comedy you know we have a lot of
episodes about
you know how to write jokes and youtube
videos about that so i mean if you just
go on youtube and search a question
chances are like we've
from hot breath have made a video about
it uh or a podcast about it so yeah tap
into the hot breath verse here too
um
jordan
asking when are you well he didn't say
when are you i think he said it with a
little little attitude he goes when you
coming to cali
okay i'm actually i'm doing a show in in
irvine um april 2nd
at uh irvine barkley theater
so um oh theaters oh well like that like
that
like
small small theaters flex but whenever
you say theater though it's like you
know yeah you got to see the theater in
it yeah how much does it hold up 20 20
people
it's in the parking lot of the theater
but it's still the theater yeah yeah
it's at the theater but it's in the you
know the ticket box office
so april uh april 2nd yeah um it's going
to go on sale and hopefully in february
but we already got that spot booked so
um yeah all the guys out there
all the local people you guys can come
make it to that
yeah and anyone that listens to this
podcast if you see
that tamu is going to be in your area
pull up and let them know the hot breath
versus
out chia supporting
um
we have ben webb here
he asks uh what is one thing you have
learned doing comedy that you have
carried over and applied to your own
life
um
i would say um
never giving up you know i mean there
was a few times where i bombed in the
beginning of my career and i really
questioned myself like it was just this
is for me you know i'm sure you you had
that too all of all his comics for sure
has those big bomb stories yup
um but yeah i would say never giving up
but
i would i kind of
flip it because coming from an athlete
background um
and just learning about consistency and
and integrity and all that it i use that
to help with my comedy so i like i take
my my sports background and the way i
would you know train for football
constantly and i kind of
use it in in
in comedy and
you know using my effort and being
consistent trying to write every day you
know i mean i'm still struggling with
that i'm sure a lot of comics are but
yeah you still do the right ten club
every day yeah i don't go live every day
oh okay i remember i i tuned in a few
times but it's always like four in the
morning over here because of the time
difference oh wow yeah every day dude i
did that for over 400 days in a row wow
i was live every day five hours of
material dude it was so much like well i
mean they're not all great they weren't
all great
i think
i i ended up crying on one of them i had
like a mental breakdown i was like all
right i need to i need to reassess what
i'm doing here i was like just drained
but uh yeah i used to do it every day
but we still do it in the facebook group
um i'll go live every wednesday and do a
live stream but uh every day we post a
new word in there as like a writing
prompt to get the juices flowing
yeah that's that's a great you know you
know group that you got there to write
10 club and i appreciate it really it
really helps with the creativity and
gets you writing like you may be
probably not going to use that joke in
your set but at least you have your pen
in your hand and you're like oh i'm
going to start writing now and do
exactly
and that's what i use it for yeah like i
don't the vast majority of jokes i've
written do in that right tin exercise
which
if if you're listening and you haven't
heard of this it's like
you get a random word and then 10
minutes to write a joke using that word
and it's just it's just a good exercise
it's a good warm-up exercise before you
actually maybe start getting into your
material you know so
if you're looking for
you want to write every day
a great way to do that is just join our
facebook group and then look at the word
write a joke with it and then that kind
of you're like oh okay
i
i started writing and i can build on
that momentum you know it's just a way
to like
write without like thinking or really
having to like
be have you ever have you ever done
those
some clubs do we do it here in hawaii
where it's like
um like improv on the stand up on the
spot we call it stand up on the spot
where they would have a they put up a
random word behind you and you got to
come up with a bit on stage in front of
a live audience oh
yeah
they're fun they're scary you know you
don't know you don't have anything you
just see the word okay i'm gonna try to
come up with something but that's also
like that can also spark some creativity
or or motivation to to write something
but that really puts you into like the
the fight-or-flight mode and on stage
and what are you gonna do to to win this
audience you know without no material
and a big thing as well is like
uh accountability or some sort of like
you know that our facebook group is now
almost 5 000
comedians
uh around the world not only doing the
right tank club but motivating each
other answering each other's questions
really just supporting each other so
it's like any time a comic is feeling
unmotivated like you know jumping into
that group and connecting with someone
and people make a lot of friends in
there and that
it can be difficult because like
we want to write every day but when it's
just you
then it's some days you may not feel
like it and if you miss one day it turns
into a month very quickly you know but
you you with the sports background you
know i mean you know i played d3
football so you know i know what it's
like to be
would you play receiver
i used to be like 240. i was a dm oh
really oh he's the end wow don't make me
come off the edge with a little
difference
maybe do a little dipping rip on ya
how tall are you i was slow i was six
i'm six four
oh wow
you're same sizes as my dad well i'm
five five nine i'm still waiting for my
grilled square
[Music]
how old are you
but your dad played the nfl right and
your uncle yeah yeah they both played so
i mean they're both well known in hawaii
too so i mean i had that you know
that expect expectations of just being
in the nfl or or following their
footsteps and um
i did i mean my dad played at uh
university of hawaii and i wanted to to
follow in his footsteps and i've gone
there i never play as much as i
i wanted to play but um i still was on
special teams and i still traveled with
the team so that was good memories and
just being around with the boys and
traveling every other week you know good
to get out of hawaii and that's actually
where i found comedy so i could have
easily went to
a d3 school i feel like and play a lot
more in the mainland but um i decided to
stay home i walked on
i ended up getting a scholarship
my junior year
so that was great yeah and i just was
doing that and and comedy you know
oh yeah jordan says uh bose represent
oh he was well i guess he's your fellow
alumni i don't know he says bozo do you
say bose for short or did he just yeah
so they're known as the rainbow warriors
yeah but do you say bose is see
that like yeah gobos yeah that's the
goldballs
oh dude um mel girl here said we went to
the blaisdell show and it was awesome
oh right on yeah thank you yeah
and she asked uh winner oh gosh i don't
wanna i feel like a colonizer trying to
say words i just is there a way i can
see the comments too or no um these are
they're on youtube so youtube yeah
they're on our youtube channel so if you
like pull it up on youtube you can see
comments
um
but um
when are you
when are you gonna
hanau
hanahu on oahu
when are you gonna try to spell the word
h-a-n-a-h-o-u
oh hana hole so hana-ho means like you
know
that's like it's similar to encore that
they yell out in the crowd ah
okay
that means they want you to come again
you know so
then we're gonna come back on oahu so
yeah so i'm gonna actually come back to
the blaisdell um
uh aiming in november so november time
i'm gonna be back um
after the the tour so
wow
i will announce the the date soon but
yeah just keep the month of november
open
that's very nice look you got fans in
here this is so cool yeah and um
oh jordan said um his mom is an alum
from pearl city
okay
right on i don't know where any of that
is um i'm not sure
it's all cities in hawaii
so what do you what do you think like
how with where you're at in your career
now it's like
i don't know you like build on social
media and you then you like sell to
blaisdell three times and now you're
looking for the mainland like how how
far down the road are you looking now
it's almost like
at a point now it's like a chameleon
looking on it's like oh man he made it
he did it he built a following and he's
selling out venues now it's like so how
far down the line are you looking what
are you what are you aspiring to like to
do with what you've built here
um
well part of the reason why i wanted to
get into comedy was to be an actor i
always wanted to and that's why i i
minored in theater at uh 2 university of
hawaii um
and i felt like
comedy is the quickest way to acting if
you look at the one of the big time a
few of the big time actors they all
started off in comedy you know adam
sandler um even tom hanks a lot of
people don't know that but he started
off as a stand-up comedian
yeah wow
all these guys um
and i actually did actually i got a
speaking role on ncis hawaii um oh yeah
the photographer photographer yeah and
it all started as the one of the writers
were fans of me and followed me on on
social media and then they reached out
to me and said oh we have a we have a
role for you if you want to audition for
it so
hoping to do more acting roles um and
just
continue to to tour and and do bigger
bigger venues in the mainland and just
spread out my
my my fans and and
and my followers and just grow you know
i'm just taking it one one step one year
at a time
wow interesting okay okay so you're
building an empire here okay i i
see what you're doing
what you're doing
and i think i think that's a big thing
you said um just for ben asking
something you learned in comedy that you
cared over and applied to your life i
think i think for me the big thing was
like
resilience and it's like
well if if i can bomb
then i can handle sitting in this
traffic jam or something like it it
really adds a lot of context to just
like
just like what is a dire situation what
you're just being dramatic about like i
think it i think
i feel like anyone everyone should try
stand up anyone who's ever thought about
it should at least
scratch that itch and get on stage at
least once just to know because it
really
it's like just your survival instincts
kick in like it's just you up there and
your words and you've got to
entertain strangers you know that you
learn a lot about yourself just through
that process
that's the second greatest fear in the
world i mean after death right is uh or
is it first public speaking
i don't i've heard it's up there i've
heard it yeah it's up there yeah yeah
so it's it's worth it's worth trying out
for anyone and david said i'm in hawaii
and we'll be out tonight it'll be my
fourth time up
oh he's he's gonna go up oh right on
so what would you say as we as we start
to land this plane here like
what
what kind of advice would you have just
for
the comedians in general because
honestly like you're the new blueprint
it's no longer
like burke chrysler like you said he
reached out to you when you sold out the
blazedale
he he's in that old school of like grind
it out on the road for 20 years and then
maybe you'll make it type deal and it
worked out for him thanks to social
media though he went viral on facebook
the machine story
so
but the new wave is it's what you're
doing five years in and boom you're
selling out
three times
selling out it's just incredible dude so
like for a comedian starting out here
and they see that social media is the
way
like what what kind of
advice that maybe you've had to learn
the hard way a few things that maybe you
could bestow upon comedians here
just just never quit never give up
there's there's many comedians that i
know that stop trying because
they didn't go viral or um they didn't
they didn't find their voice or they
never get their big break just keep
trying i feel like now is
the fastest and easiest way to go viral
is through tick tock honestly um so much
people gain followers on tick tock and
because they the algorithm is that they
they send it out to you know not just
your followers but
everyone it's just i don't know like the
exact it might even be fake because it's
a chinese company but i don't know
what's going on over there i'm still
halfway scared but i'm on there so it's
like too late i'm like i don't want to
do it but like dude you're on there it's
like
it's too late
i gotcha
no yeah tick-tock is is awesome i mean
that's probably the quickest way but my
best advice would be don't give up and
stay consistent on social media um
be true to your fans interact with them
more i got a lot of advice from you know
who vegas dave is
no
yeah he's a um
he's a sports bettor guy but you check
them out on on instagram but yeah he's
telling me you know some tips on social
media and just to be interactive with
your fans train them and
know like
just like how you have a consistent
thing of going live every wednesday you
know that's i gotta try to do something
like that to have a a schedule that
would would train my followers to be
okay i gotta tune in to
to you know the hot breath at that
wednesday you know so be consistent find
a find a um
a schedule that fits for you um back
when i was pumping out videos i would
try to do one
every four days at the most twice a week
you know would be good
i don't know how those guys do it like
charlie barons and posts out every every
day that's a lot of i think they film it
all one time and then yeah does it yeah
that's the only way i can think of doing
that but yeah you can just be consistent
and and just keep trying don't give up
um
i would say don't
over use yourself though i mean
it's okay to say no sometimes for people
or people requesting some things you
know you don't want to
make them tired of you you know don't
over post don't like post like four
times a day because then it's it's just
like what are you doing you know
[Laughter]
but yeah like
be consistent and like
there's a few times where i would have a
video and i would be like oh this is not
funny i'm not gonna post it like i
wasted all this time editing it and not
posting it but i would say just post it
like you know you're not gonna have
your best video every single time just
like i i know you mention it like the
the joke ratio if you write 20 jokes
only two of them is gonna be really
funny you know so
not every video is gonna go viral so
just keep pumping them out but don't put
out too much you know but
if you don't think it's funny it might
be funny to other people so just
just put whatever you can and just don't
give up
yeah it's kind of like you hear a lot of
like famous musicians say the song that
blew up was the song they weren't even
gonna release they were just like yeah
so like i made this video on on youtube
this halloween video with my friend oh
it has 11 million views or something
crazy seven million feels yeah
and that was the least video i've ever
thought i didn't even post it on on
instagram or facebook because i was like
this is not funny for instagram like my
fans are not gonna laugh at this but so
i just put it up on youtube and um
it blew up 11 million views uh i don't
know how i'm guessing it has to do with
the dallas cowboys because i did a joke
about
it dallas a lot of like the sports fans
kind of saw that and
and was doing that because i'm a dallas
cowboys fan you know so i was kind of
ragging on them but
this is our year every year is our year
but this year
oh that's interesting yeah yeah okay
yeah cause i did see that one had 11
million
and that's that's funny that yeah you
didn't even expect it to didn't expect
it and i wasn't even trying to like
you know
make it universal so that everyone would
understand this video like i still was
doing my same hawaii style
pigeon you know accent and all that and
it still blew up
and um and you made it and it's crazy
because i wasn't monetized by then if i
was monetized on youtube
because you didn't have enough
subscribers i didn't have enough
subscribers back yet back then yeah but
then that video kind of like gained me a
lot of subscribers
yeah so now i'm monetized and
i still gotta learn how to use youtube
better you know i i gotta i just post
the same video on all platforms facebook
instagram tick tock
um twitter and youtube
um but i gotta make videos like more
specific to each platform i think that's
what i got to work on now because no
sense posting the same video on every
platform
well yeah learn from the people that are
you know charlie barrens is a great
example of
um someone who's been able to go across
multiple platforms and really like build
up desi banks another one you know so
yeah you he's he's he's i'm impressed
with him because he hasn't been doing
stand-up for a while either yeah he's
like
he's i think he has over a million
followers almost 2 million i guess but
like everywhere everyone knows him and a
lot of um
big-time celebrities are like shouting
him out and all that and that's crazy
yeah dude yeah i think when i
interviewed him he had maybe been doing
stand-up like two years at that point
and he's headlining already too yeah
he's headlining he's he's selling haters
you know like yeah he's killing it he's
yeah he's definitely that social media
generation of like he blew up and is now
like figuring out stand-up but
but he was on vine first right yeah he
was on vine first and then blew up there
doing like a similar character to what
he's doing now
yeah but what's so funny is like he's
actually
a very thoughtful
soft-spoken person and half the comments
on his interview on our youtube
is like either he's he's doing his white
voice for the white man or like oh
i didn't know he talks like a square
like
or he's doing a fake voice like all of
his followers think he actually talks
like his character on social media it's
really right right
in real time
he has good strategies like
if you really watch what he does on
instagram every video he posts he goes
live right before he posts it yep and
he's like comment post and tag he like
yeah
and he shows himself
commenting to all of them so yeah i mean
that makes you want to be like oh i want
to say something he's going to reply to
me i want to say something you know so
that just builds the whole algorithm and
also because when you go live on
instagram that that story thing it stays
in the front
no matter what it doesn't go so you're
going to see that the whole time where
on your phone said oh he has a new video
i got to check it out so he's very very
smart the way he he advertises himself
and he does it um he does it also where
he'll make a post that says new vid and
it's like a screenshot of
so these are all things we can learn
from you know yeah yeah put i'd have to
put my ego aside and be like all right
i'm gonna go live and then it's like
four people two of them are my parents
and i'm like go comment like and tag
everyone yeah or whatever he's like
scrolling through thousands of people
i'd be like thousands of people yeah
but that's part of the hustle it's part
of the grind to build up but it's cool
to and it's good to observe what is
working for people you know like you
mentioned country wayne earlier
country wayne a lot of his stuff is
serialized so it's like
a character
that you're following through a couple
like
like i don't know how he does it he
posts like five minute videos every day
well a lot of those people now i haven't
had country wayne on yet but i mean a
lot of them now run like a studio i mean
they have like they have like writers
and they have like a production schedule
where it's like on this day we're
recording five skits and then we're
gonna release them in this sequence like
it's a well-oiled machine but you know
as a machine just like andrew schultz
too he has his own studio and yep and
everything he came a long way too and
same thing with social media i know you
had him on here earlier yeah yeah we
have to get him back now that he that
was a very one of my favorite episodes
you did
you know because
yeah he had some good tips
and because i kind of used his strategy
too with like my crowd work i would post
stand-up videos with but just crowd work
so you're saving material but you're
still getting you know your point across
and um
the local people love it because
my shows they know that i film every
show i have three different camera
angles and one of my friends on a gimbal
so i i film all the the interactions
with the crowd work and and
they notice that so they're very
talkative at my shows too and they want
to be part of the show in the camera
when i post it you know oh that's
awesome
like i would get comments they're like
oh where's where's um
brought a bill like that one interaction
can you post that one and i was like
yeah i got it i'm gonna edit it soon you
know so they would remember what would
happen at the shows and they want me to
post about it so he i mean some of his
most popular videos are just the crowd
work stuff it's all crowd work yeah so
that's you know that that's another way
to like fill time as a stand-up is doing
crowd work and the people love it you
know like the i seen him live at blue
note and he had like
20 minutes of hawaii material and it's
like
material where you're like how does this
guy notice he's not even from here this
is like really really local jokes you
can check it out on um on his youtube he
posted the whole
20 minutes of i think it's like hawaii
got these jokes of him performing in
hawaii wow
check that out which which i in my
opinion would gain your fan base a lot
in hawaii and that's what jokoy did too
he has a lot of hawaii material which
which is why he's like a god here in
hawaii you know because they think he's
he's one of us you know and we're also
like how does he know this he's not even
from here you know even gabriel too
gabriel glacis has a lot of hawaii jokes
really um
yeah
i think that's that's my advice if you
ever come to hawaii just have like maybe
10 minutes of hawaii material and um i
can i can give you some tips of what to
say or what what the lingo around here i
feel like i always look like i'm coming
to build a resort or something that's
what i look like i'm coming in
to a resort here right
that's what i feel like all like the
real experienced comics do when they
tour is they do they open up with some
some local jokes no matter where they're
at and win the audience over right off
the beginning yeah um
that's that's i feel like andrew schultz
does that a lot because i watch a lot of
his his crowd work stuff and it's a lot
of them is about what city he's in too
you know so
that's a that's a great tip to use as a
as a road comic
well as we as we land this plane here
please promote where the hot breath
verse can follow you or contact you if
they heard this episode and they're like
oh this was amazing i want to reach out
and ask a question or just show
gratitude for coming on the show
you can um you can follow me on
instagram at uh tumul underscore
t-u-m-u-a
underscore um and then i did underscore
because someone has tomorrow already i
don't know who it is
yeah so this is the underscore or you
can go on my website at my website at
tomoa comedy.com um i post everything on
social media where i'm gonna be
performing at my videos my skits um
youtube you can catch me at tomorrow
tween a
and
facebook tomorrow twin a as well so
well tamua thank you so much for being
on here my friend it's so cool to
connect with you through a dm of you
asking me a podcasting question to now
you're on
the podcast sharing your story and
hopefully inspiring other people to like
you know start taking their career into
their own hands you've done it my you're
just getting started i don't want i
don't want to come off as if i'm saying
you did it man it's all cruise control
from here like you're still just getting
started but just to be able to
recognize how far you've come in such a
short amount of time but also
recognize the amount of work that you
put in to do it as well so
thank you for the inspiration and thank
you for sharing your time with us
no problem thank you thank you hot
breath verse and hot brethrens and
sister ins yeah
[Laughter]
it's an honor to be here i'm a i was i
was a fan you know so i still am a fan
and um yeah let me know if you ever come
to hawaii we can hook something up or
if i'm ever up near atlanta or not but
absolutely go for appreciate it hop
breath the verse go reach out to tamua
check out his content but do reach out
to him and let him know you heard him on
the show and that you loved what he said
and we'll be back next week with another
hot breath
you can do it can you do it you know it
i remember the other one you did the hot
brush
do you still do that or no yeah i do it
at the end now at the end oh yeah i do
it at the end
i do it for the people that listen to
the outro i'll i'll end the episode you
gotta stay after the credits like a
marvel movie exactly i used it at the
beginning and then um my wife got in my
head and said it was cringy so now i
only do it at the end that's your that's
your that's your signature you got to
keep that i should do it i should bring
it back to the beginning good bring it
back like how you brought back the dab
i legit thought that was gonna be my
social media
trip i was like i'm just gonna dab on
social media and i'm gonna bring it back
like backpack kid
i'm gonna be the dab guy and then i did
it for like a week and was like oh it
didn't go viral so never mind
that's okay just keep trying just try
something else yeah i don't know the dab
i mean it sticks people that saw it
remember it so maybe i should i yeah i
remembered it i mean
i think what you're doing is great
because i'm like all in hawaii and i've
heard about your podcast you know so
you're reaching people and like the
comedy community here we know about your
podcast too so we talk about it and we
use it for for tips and all that too so
um keep doing what you're doing i mean
this is this is huge i mean i'm a really
big fan of the podcast and it's an honor
to be on here so wow thank you again wow
thank you man it's cool to see the tips
in action it's like you learned and
applied and now you're on the show
that's so cool
yeah
this is just the beginning my friend
we'll definitely be doing some shows
together for sure for sure yeah
all right all right hot breath the verse
we'll see y'all next week
bye
you